Mình cho ông ấy, nghe một bệnh một công bố thách trặt quy định cấp thị thật scan danh cho công dân gà và xem sẽ thả năng trên khai
lực lượng và lựa con sử dụng đại ucolina sau khi xung đột két thúc. Theo,
huy bán cho ông, từ nay, công dân gà sẽ không được cấp thị thật nhập cảnh nhiều lần và
phải nột hồ xơ mới cho một chuyện đi. Giúp cả nước thành viện tăng cường kẹp sã an ninh và sàng lập
tý hơn từ chân hợp. Cuối điện phủ trách nổi vụ và dịch gương mát nước sBRN ở cho bến,
tóan bộ hồ xơ sinh tý thật của công dân gà sẽ chạy qua quy trình xâm mình giêm gà hơn, giám dạm
tụi gió có thể sẽ ra, cùng ngày chụi tệ của i bán quân sự EU tưởng xong tàn xí cho bến,
khói đăng cân nhắc trên khai các chuyện ra hình lệ của thổ phá bộ hồ chạp của sự EU và lãnh tổ của
gái nâ sau khi trên sự chấm dân. Ông như mạnh được dịch dịch trên một phần được lượng này sẽ là phần
an tối i của đe cùng của năng lực phòng thủ cho kẹp và an ninh lâu dài của cả cho
bảo kế hoạch nằm trong quân khổ lộ trình sản xảm của phòng má EU đặc mừng tiêu đặt
khả năng dân đe chức nằm hành hi bà mời tưởng kênh xí khẳng định,
nà tổ vấn sế là chụi có an ninh chụi chụi chụi chụi, sông bộ qua hệ xuyên đặt tây dương sẽ được
bá cân bằng ký cho hồ dần được chụ hơn về năng lực của phòng.